the pixel 7A is the latest on Google it
seems to be quite the contender for one
of the best Android phones on the market
with some great cameras that we tested
out you can check it out like right here
but we are going to be gaming with it
and putting it through the gauntlet of
Kenshin impact honkai stereo pubg mobile
and Call of Duty mobile to see how well
the pixel 7e Works performance wise for
the pixel 7A that we are using has a
Google tensor G2 a Mali g710 MP7 for its
GPU 8 gigs of RAM 128 gigs of storage
and everything plays out on a 90hz 6.1
inch screen with a 4 385 milliamp hour
battery alright so let's just remove
this cover real quick and do a baseline
temperature check right
stick the front
about 32
pretty all right check the back
33 32 ish nothing too crazy all right so
we have that down let's get into our
first game Kenshin impact alright so we
are finally engag and let's just check
our settings real quick oh let me just
raise the volume also the first thing of
the bat is that both speakers are at the
bottom of the phone so you got to watch
out for that because your hands will cup
it use earphones or Bluetooth earphones
or headphones either one works alright
so let's check our Graphics real quick
we are at very high for everything 60
FPS the highest the game can allow us
and after that everything else is turned
on so let's just get into it because as
it is there's a lot of frame start doing
already all right so let's just check
out ayaka's model real quick
and as you can see she's looking pretty
swell I like how the security I'm
falling all around here it actually
looks it looks really good in person as
well it's just that
we will see a lot of flames starting
later on especially if you start running
down
this is on the higher settings for the
pixel by the way and again this is not a
gaming phone but we are gonna push it to
its limits and just see how far we can
take it
all right so let's just run through in
the zoom on real quick I'll rather glide
through oh you can see that
frame starting already
that's been pretty often
other than that you know it is playable
but not a huge family job right there it
is playable but you're gonna need to get
used to you know learning how to play
with all the frame starting and
everything if you're going to play on
the highest of things obviously you know
with the lower settings no problem
whatsoever all right with this let's
move on to exploration and maybe some
combat
look at that okay besides that even with
the random distance it looks really good
it's pretty sick
except for the three or eight drops but
yes let's move on
so I guess we did a bit better in the
city
compared to being out here so we are
going through the forests of
Samir right now and let's just try and
get into a fight I think I see some mobs
over there
I believe
those are morbs
all right let's just keep moving
all right let's fight
completely missed out but never mind
let's go download
oh oh okay yeah it's okay I may need to
drop this down a little bit
boy
[Music]
that is quite a big drop
okay I think we've seen enough I don't
think I expect much of this
I'm pretty sure with the lower settings
again look pretty damn well but again we
are playing engine
all right let's push on
all right let's activate another ulti
[Applause]
still very very dinky
oh boy
okay so we are in the abyss right now
don't call me out for the team
competition I am actually not the best
engine player for this kind of thing
that'll be such yeah so let's just move
on and start killing things
all right let's hit an old people quick
all right
all right here
oh boy
it's a little bit better here I mean
because you know we are in a confined
area beyond that many things that the
phone needs to worry about like you know
like qualities and everything it's doing
relatively well
so I think with the spiral of this you'd
it won't be so bad
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go
all right so with that we have come to
the end of our Genji impact around let's
check temperatures real quick
the front Fufu 40 degrees celsius 39
degrees Celsius it is pretty toasty down
here let's check the sides real quick
we are looking at about
37 inch 39ish just on the sides down
here almost 40 and on the back let's
check it out it's actually pretty all
right
at the back 39-ish 38-ish all right yeah
so it is a pretty toasty fold when it
comes to these games so it cannot run
the eyes of things that's for damn sure
but you can definitely get some gaming
on this if you lower the set things and
with that I am kind of concerned for
honkai stereo so let's just move on to
that right now
all right so before we start honkai
stereo we are at 91 battery
the entire Playstation only took us nine
percent and I only play about like 15
minutes so that's not too bad if you do
the match you know you know how long the
phone will last if you play much longer
so let's just check the back real quick
we're coming hard of the heels of Genji
impact career 39 degrees right now it
has gone down a little bit from just now
and I just I mean like literally just a
second ago and the front oh no and the
front we are at 40 degrees still it is
taking a bit too cool down so
let's just enter honkai stereo all right
so now we are in Hong Kai style rail
it's looking pretty good let's check the
settings real quick very high resolution
60 FPS everything is looking good so
let's give it a shot she's looking
pretty alright as you can see the
details are pretty okay
and yeah not really a lot of frame drops
a little bit of frame starting here and
there but let's move on and see what
Japan has for us
let's see how we handles cutscene
I mean it's a very
story driven base game anyway so
let's just try and Skip all this stuff
I've already played this during the
closed beta that we had so I kind of
know what's going on already
all right so let's just do some
exploration and so far it's looking
pretty good A bit janky on the highest
the highest settings
and
that's it's all right so far it's okay
so just running around Bella box square
it's not the smoothest experience it's a
bit janky a little frame something here
and there a bit of frame dropping here
and there but not as much as I expected
so I'll just keep playing until I get in
some combat and we'll see how it fares
from there okay so when it comes to the
mini games it's you know pretty smooth
because you know it the phone isn't
really doing much other than that but
let's just do a quick one
and yeah it's very smooth but the main
gameplay isn't as smooth so let's just
keep going
I believe you can just collect this guy
here we go
all right I'm gonna go with our
specialist
there we go not too bad
not too shabby
okay so combat is pretty much all right
actually
let's do this calyx thing throw
let's do a special off the bat let's do
another special to get the other guy
and I don't think okay I'm playing it on
Lego two times speed because I don't
really like waiting that much
but so far combat seems alright even at
this level it's not too bad
let's do it without fast forwarding
actually just for this one
and then let's go into our all these
okay
it is a bit janky even on 60fps and the
phone it starts to heat up a little bit
we'll check that in a bit let's extract
these guys
all right it's one down
I almost went down
may or may not survive this but we shall
see
and yeah
let's hit this guy
and then it hit the other guy
[Music]
so I think from the gameplay so far you
can tell that you know it runs smooth
when it comes to these combating
counters but it doesn't really run as
smooth when it comes to exploration and
whatnot give me some Cuts using the
let's just do a quick temperature check
so right now it is 38 39ish on the front
which isn't that bad actually
and then oh and just get this guy
all right still not dead yet we'll deal
with that later on let's check the back
we are at 38 37 ish
39-ish okay it is getting a bit hot on
the top half
and for the sides we are looking at
about come on
oh let's try to get this out here
37ish 36 inch 38ish on these sides of
the phone so not that great final
thoughts wise that would be pretty much
it it does a great job when it comes to
these encounters but it doesn't do a
great job when it comes to
you know exploration and whatnot even
some cutscenes are a little bit janky so
let's put more to our next game called
Beauty mobile before we get into it this
channel is supported by Brands who help
us improve our content and keep us going
so stay around for this sponsored
message if you're looking for a laptop
that does it all gaming streaming and
content creation then look no further
than the Rog Surfers M16 the first
16-inch laptop with an anime Matrix LED
array so you can showcase your inner
geek to the World featuring a 16x10
aspect ratio QHD Pantone validated Rog
nebula display this display not only
looks great but also offers
unprecedented performance thanks to its
240Hz refresh rate and 3 milliseconds
response time with all that power comes
with full width heatsink supported by
Rog intelligent cooling with tri-fan
technology to keep the laptop cool while
intense gaming or heavy workloads for
more details check out asus.com
currently we are at 76 for battery let's
do a temperature check we just came off
honkai stereo and 35
yeah actually cool down pretty quick
36.8 not too bad check the back
we are running at 36 there's 36 is yeah
not too bad actually the top half
it actually has gone down quite a bit so
with that let's move on to Call of Duty
mobile okay so we are very high for
graphic quality frame rates on Max can't
do ultra because very high graphics and
Ultra do not agree with each other and
then heading down we're going to be
checking our multiplayer everything is
turned on and let's do a shaded preload
okay shade preload Shader preload there
we go
all right let's restart our game and get
back into it
classical yes
[Applause]
oh this is good actually the audio is
pretty all right just kind of loud
it's not the best but it does the job
oh
oh okay I killed myself basically if I
keep someone else so that's okay
and so far it's actually pretty smooth I
mean Call of Duty mobile is one of the
least intensive games on this list
I'll start doing that I've seen so far
and the quality is pretty good I can see
how the light reacts it's a bit janky
but it's fine
just get out of here
and push on okay that's not our flame
let's get out of here
get a bit of frame something you just
saw that it's a little bit
look at this guy
get someone nice one big game on our
list
so let's push on the sticky
it is a bit janky here and there
a little bit but it's not that bad
it's really nice no one is taking DIA
they're taking a guy out oh
it's another
it's fine
one down two down
okay wait where are the enemies at
okay let's see
all right let's get to B real quick
okay oh my gosh yes
there we go
we're losing C right now let's go to C
since this guy has it
okay did not get it in time but yes
we're back to our gun guns dungeon guns
nicely done
and then we uh we've won
so pretty quick but this is what you're
gonna expect from Call of Duty Mobile on
the pixel 7A it's a really smooth
experience when it comes to these kind
of games when it's less demanding even
on the highest set things so let's just
check temperatures real quick not much
frame start doing not much pre-made
drops actually I don't think there were
any favorite jobs whatsoever but I will
say there was a bit of stuff to get in
there so you'll need to get used to that
but 37-ish 38ish I could hardly feel
anything it's not really uncomfortable
or anything that's super noticeable
let's check it back
and 36 years 37ish all right 38 okay
sick
so with that let's move on to our final
game pubg mobile okay so before we get
into pubg mobile let's check
temperatures real quick and we are
currently at 32-ish
all right let's go down a little bit
pretty good at heat dissipation if I say
so and bottom I'm in the back sorry back
at the bottom 32-ish and yeah oh it's
actually doing a pretty damn good job at
heat dissipation so
and let's get into bubble G mobile pubg
let's just check our settings real quick
and graphics and here we go all three HD
for graphics Ultra frame rate two times
NTA listen because four times it's still
unavailable and shadows are enabled and
everything looks set so let's just
restart the game and get into a match
now as you wait for the match to start
it's looking pretty alright so far
animations are pretty smooth the sun is
moving off color the jacket as it should
be so I think we should be in for your
game
aiming for hospital for this one let's
see the trajectory oh never mind and I'm
alone
great
all right all right all right see you
under this looking good
let's check out
the map real quick and where am I
hitting
okay A bit far from hospital so let's
just get off at shelter okay actually
you know what's going on
right it's going milta
one jump
okay so far the drop is pretty smooth
I'm not seeing any other squats with us
so this should be all right
okay let's keep going down and down and
down and down
and we're still it's still pretty smooth
I mean pubg isn't a very you know
demanding game so to expect a bit more
from this compared to the likes of Genji
impact than Hong Kai Rio honkai star
real my bad so let's just get into a
house
I'm gonna try and get the hospital after
this is on the other side of the map but
I kind of like fighting there
all right
let's see okay go to Ump
very nice
shotgun very nice
all right so before I fight the
transport which I sure hope I do let's
see the scope real quick and it looks
pretty alright I guess if I can go to
the first person mode things are looking
pretty alright if you can see the rifle
looks quite nice
and then looking around I mean things
are okay especially at this Graphics but
like so far no huge frame rate drops or
you know frame start doing whatsoever we
are doing a-okay
no they're all fighting over there
that's very close
it's one down
there should be more
where
oh okay I see him
okay I think in the long run the twofold
Bravo didn't mean any good so I'm going
to be switching over to his car
that would be the wise technical
decision
nope
where is that shot coming from oh
there's someone behind me
did you get that monster truck
and everything will be okay
getting shot up on the front kind of
really tough I'm wearing
so those shots are landing pretty close
oh
okay
just trying to
deny me transportation
let's screw that guy let's go
it's a really good thing I I took them
onto the truck because I think the u.sb
yeah he ain't getting us you're not
getting us
yeah terrible aim
all right
yeah you guys are terrible at this
let's get in the circle before
oh we are in the circle sick all right
let's get to the Ozark
but yeah so far I believe the 57a is
doing a pretty good job I think this is
a safe place
so let's just do a quick temperature
check
uh 31 or 36ish it's not a very demanding
game so it's doing pretty all right
let's check the back
study 8 is 37ish at the top here not too
bad
as we go down the line 37 36 ish all
right that's fine in the sides
34 yeah they aren't really as they're
not really heating up like say with uh
Hong Kai or ginshin so we're doing
pretty alright so let's just keep moving
through Ozark let's see if we can win
this game
okay never mind I died because I forgot
how to exit the vehicle but
yes it's as far as we'll get with the
girl pubg for now usually we get wins
but ah whatever it's okay it is what it
is so uh with that let's move on to the
final conclusion for the pixel 7A let's
do a final temperature check as well we
are currently at 65 battery and
temperature check 37ish 37 inch 38 ish
not too bad
check the front
and we are doing a okay actually now
that those some very okay-ish readings
all right let's move on to our
conclusion
the pixel 7e has done surprisingly well
in the thermal management sector even
though it gets up to as high as 40
degrees celsius at times it dissipates
heat pretty quickly and I will say the
speakers can get really loud and
actually sound decent only thing is
you're not going to get any highly
demanding game sessions out of this so
keep the graphics for say again shin and
honkai star rail at medium and maybe
slap on 60fps if you're feeling lucky
that's all about the phone can truly
manage without giving you a stuttering
frame dropping experience but for what
it's worth you can get some gaming out
of it I believe the pixel 7A is a very
well-rounded phone and really is worth a
shot if you're looking to upgrade if you
have any questions about the pixel 7A
leave them in the comment section below
and I'll do my best to get to them keep
up to date with us by following all of
our socials for the latest news and if
you like this video consider hitting the
like And subscribe button it goes a long
way if you want to see more stuff check
this out
foreign